foreign
Matthew is in Grand Rapids Matthew
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys how you doing good doing great
how can we help yeah so first want to
give a quick comment I submitted for the
student loan repayment since we paid him
off during covid and I checked my Nelnet
student loan account today and I found
out they are making me pay that back and
if I didn't find that out by June 30th I
would have student loan interest I would
have to pay on top of that so this
morning paid that right back so just
wanted to give a little awareness let me
get this clear Matthew you made your
payments and they said hey we'll
actually refund you ten thousand dollars
they reinstate your balance to 10 and
say hey hopefully the government clears
that
yep so I got a check from the Department
of Education November last year for that
10 grand and my balance was 10 grand so
then next thing I uh they said by June
30th so I didn't pay that back I'd have
interest to pay on top of that and since
there was some cares act thing I
actually have to obtain an additional 20
because from 20 20 of Interest accrued
which is gracious excuse to confuse me
so uh probably some not nice words our
Lord and savior wouldn't want me to stay
on it so they wrote my 10 grand and then
put you in debt for another 10 grand and
said all right good luck pay it off wow
okay good reminder for those out there
that got a check check your balances
because they're probably reinstated for
that same amount go pay that off
immediately good looking out Matthew and
it's interesting you know I was on a
couple weeks back with Dave and a guy
called in and something really similar
he had the he had requested a refund for
the 10K and when they gave him the
refund they reinstated his entire loan
and they sent him a check for the amount
of the entire loan not just for the
ticket way more than 10K way more I
think it was like 20 it was a weird
number it was like 21 or 22 something
and this is what I was afraid of which
is you know gross predatory malpractice
from these student loan companies it's
predatory and but but Matt did the right
thing he sent that check right back and
that's what y'all need to do if you're
listening and you requested student loan
forgiveness especially if you were
already clear of debt just be debt free
man amen just be debt free send that
money back and be debt free quit waiting
on the government love it well Matthew
let's get to your question is it related
unrelated yeah uh not directly related
to this just had a quick question so my
wife and I debt-free other than our
house we uh make about 120 000 a year
combined my company uh matches about
eight to nine percent in our 401K I have
about like 50 000 in there so far and my
question is
should I only match up to the eight to
nine percent and then go with a smart
investor Pro for the others uh six six
to seven percent or should I max out
that 401k to the 15 and then let them uh
match up to that eight or nine do you
have a Roth 401k
I believe so it's uh after it's uh after
tax
it is after tax so therefore to make
sure it's a Roth if it's a Roth you can
just invest all 15 into that 401k
okay and you should get close to maxing
it out I don't think you'll get there
with your income
okay but if it's if it's not a Roth if
it's a traditional then we would just
into the Roth IRA yeah and Max that out
or get us as high as you can up to the
15.
okay that sounds good kids because yeah
I have that 15 just taken out of my
paycheck every single week cool yeah
it's great if it's a Roth if it's not we
want you to take advantage of in this
order match beats Roth beats traditional
so take that match up to nine percent
let's go to the Roth IRA and start
putting some money in there then if we
run out of options we can go back to the
traditional 401k to finish it out
okay is that a baby in the background I
hear yeah she we're we're just pulling
up uh uh she was just crying a little
bit in the car seat so I was trying to
keep her as calm as possible and that
that's what I was just gonna say so
should that shouldn't change anything
since she's about nine months old just
keep investing uh like we are yeah I
mean I'd open a 529 and beyond that 15
throw a little chunk of money into a 529
every month or an ESA
okay my parents and I partnered on that
so we're good to go there I love it man
what an awesome dad Matthew pump for you
I know what how old are you uh 25. oh my
goodness you guys are in such great
shape thank you so much for the call
what what an awesome scenario I love
your problem to have it never gets old
George when people are doing the right
thing I wish I was that smart at 25.
like you know if you're listening you're
frustrated because you're like gosh I
wish I you know you've all you always
hear this yeah man I wish I knew this
when I was younger hindsight is 20 20.
you know what it's not too late we got a
call from the 56 year old saying I want
to get out of debt we got a call from a
62 year old saying I want to retire with
dignity it's never too late so if you're
listening and you're 40 or 50 or 60 and
you hear these youngsters who are debt
free and they're not they're going to be
millionaires it's not too late for you
you can create a better tomorrow you
might have to work longer you might have
to sacrifice you might have to downsize
but you can retire with dignity you
don't have to die with loans in your
life leaving your family in a Lurch and
leaving you with no Legacy that's not
what I want for anyone listening and you
can change that